socialism
Sharia and everything bad these were the
ingredients chosen to create the perfect
leftist but Professor Chen accidentally
added an extra ingredient to the
concoction
progressiveness thus the squad was born
using their Ultra superpowers AOC ilhan
and Rashida have dedicated their lives
to fighting America and the forces of
[Music]
freedom
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith cry.com
mugclub for $89 annually join the fight
at lwith credit.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today
[Music]
I
know all apologize for the 5 minute late
start time today it's a little bit of a
hectic morning here the good news is
that's not because of terrorism uh in
the studio so much thankfully uh but we
do have you know let's go right to it
the rundown we have Lawrence Fox joining
the show who was just uh I guess you
would use the term canceled from GB news
for some things that he did that most
people would say are entirely reasonable
uh we are going to be discussing AOC and
her I mean I guess you could call it
um retardation as far as her
stance
[Music]
the uh CBC Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation my home country and uh their
moratorium on the word terrorist you are
not allowed to use the word terrorist oh
good now so remember I've told you
before how words matter when they try
and call you a Nazi right there there
are a lot of similarities there if they
call you a Nazi it's okay to punch nazzi
it's okay to shoot Nazis like we saw in
the uh the Pacific Northwest I can't
remember if it was Seattle or if it was
Portland where they said we got a trump
supporter boom shoot him and that works
on the flip side too if we don't refer
to Hamas as terrorists right if that's
controlled by a government funed funded
media entity then guess what well now
it's just an occupation now it's just a
violation of Human Rights and that's how
you frame the argument words matter so
my question to you is what do you think
would necessitate any type of direct us
involvement in Israel we've been talking
about that this week I think we done a
pretty good job of presenting those
points of view and to be clear if you
think that the United States should not
be involved and should not be sending
money but shouldn't be sending money to
Any Nation over there in that cess pool
of the world that does not make you
anti-semitic it makes you somebody who
has a difference uh difference of
opinion on foreign policy so we'll talk
about that in more and we have a crowded
studio today I'll get to you in a second
cap Morgan because we have third and
fourth chair today in third we have
there we go yeah cuz it's a little bit
chaotic going to be the Chicago Improv
October 27th Saturday the 28th you can
find more of his dates at brian.com and
then back because he puts a smile on our
faces Josh firestein who will be at
messy Jess's in Aberdine October 13th
both gentlemen how are you good good I
appreciate that uh mustache all I can
think of is broom service broom Ser hey
I know I know thank you I don't I want
you to look me in the eye and just right
before we you go down town I want you to
say did you just order broom service I
won't do that though that would be out
of character for me okay
no I'm just saying I like I appreciate
the mustach my way of complimenting
implication and Josh is incredibly
uncomfortable hey don't let it's okay I
like your dick duster
too I I'm not afraid to call it what it
is that is Studio terrorism right there
you're trying to make me afraid of who I
am well we'll throw up a poll because it
was just we won by a margin of 51% last
week the mustache does it St I know if I
need got to get rid of showcase it shave
your cheeks man shave the scrub I like
it you you pull it off if I wore a
mustache they' keep me away from high
schools but you look good I'm too skinny
they would have him teach PE yes exactly
yeah from my van now I love it number
two Captain Morgan CEO Gerald how are
you sir I'm doing well no you're not I'm
not I'm you're not you're saying you're
tired but you know it's a little sick
hey look we've all had there's been a
virus going through it could be the
Omicron or whichever variant but you
know what our job is to make sure that
your day is a little less crappy so you
know like I said I'm fine sometimes we
have to like we all have to be robots we
all have to make sure that hey you we we
take the arrows in the back so you don't
have to which by the way since we will
be talking about Hamas and terrorists
and uh I'm about to roll a clip where a
man uses the nword profusely don't worry
he's black he's black he can do it if at
any point you see or hear
this that's the YouTube dump button that
means head on over to uh Rumble which is
where you should be anyway because they
do not capitulate to foreign governments
right all right so we have what the
two man's just hitting
buttons you're like you said Rumble so
you were like elf in the elevator
buttons all
right and we have uh we have the new
version of this clip right yes okay good
so I don't know if you've seen this
before now now I I have spoken with a
lot of of black individuals out in the
the community you know because I'm I'm
I'm street but I I have maintained this
the democ black Democrat voters are the
moderate wing of the Democrat party
today and a lot of them obviously are
conservative and don't even realize it
yet when you drill down on values but
now we are actually seeing it uh as a
matter of polling a statistical reality
and particularly with black men so it
used to be there was kind of a novelty
right at least for let's say you know
after uh post Nixon era where there
weren't a lot of black Republicans you'd
find one you like oh let's get you on
camera and now you're seeing it's a huge
part of the community and it's not just
that they're speaking out they're
speaking out boldly with support here is
a black man who has actually started a
group I'm here to support president
Trump you want to know why I'm here to
support president Trump because they
done did black men like this for decades
make up charges and put on so I know
Trump is innocent I support Trump
against this corrupt two-tier justice
system that's why I'm here to show my
support as a black man for Trump and I'm
wearing my shirt for Trump 2024
and I mean that what do you think about
the indictments oh it's a bunch of
it's going around the country
you know fan Fanny will is she's a uh
she went to school with my sister she
full
of she's a puppet for the white liberal
and that is controlling everything she's
in front but the white Lial back there
pulling those strings telling her what
to do that's what I think about her
making a fool of herself do you think
it's going to help his election of
course it is it's going to elevate him
all way I think we should make Trump
king that's how I feel it's pronounced K
but be like kind of like communistic no
there's no way near communist now we
just going to make him King but we still
got our freedoms and right he saw that
yeah Trump for King 2024 that's actually
my URL own that URL you on that URL can
I really oh my name is for
Trump former candidate I'm a former
candidate for New York State Governor
Derek Gibson look me up by the way that
is in fact a very white finger that
comes in and says that's my bleep and
the black guy cuz he's he's rolling with
it he's just like I'm going to act like
we didn't hear that yep yep y like it's
okay all right I'll allow this one but
you can still see he goes like yeah like
he feel has that meat locker in the back
of his neck chills feeling like H when a
white guy says it but it was like him
sticking his finger in in the in the
cage of a
bear I poked it I said it I said it he's
like I'm allow at next one I'm going
beat your ass though next one I mean
that's gonna be remember I said this not
long ago we could probably pull a clip I
said this is something you are seeing
Donald Trump go through a justice system
that black Americans do not trust and by
the way rightfully so now it's not a
white black thing right we've been
through this with me too we've been
through this with people who have talked
about for example no fault divorce you
see it with political indictments you
see it with the political weapon uh the
weaponization of politics against
ideological opponents they see that with
Donald Trump and it's the first guy who
they see going through that on a
national level I mean maybe bich but you
know he wasn't president and you know
the hair so the point is they see this
and they do identify with someone that
has been a problem in their and they
have a guy who by the way Donald Trump
pardoned more black people than any
other president in modern history this
was a guy who did more for the black
community this is something that is
picking up steam now I know it's a very
small percentage of the voting block and
I'm not saying that you Pander certainly
not through things like reparations
right I'm not saying that you do that at
all but guess what the message itself
and the man who he is is effective
enough to make some changes let me give
you some numbers here just in case uh
you don't believe it so uh Donald Trump
increased his share by the way black
voters from 2016 to 2020 from 6% to 8%
in
2020 and uh it was higher for black men
it was like 12% yeah he's now averaging
20% among blacks across the board now
the last time that happened was Nixon in
72 where he won 18% of black voters that
was the highest in modern GOP history
now a lot of people don't know this
about Nixon you know Sam Sammy Davis Jr
was uninvited by JFK at one point to I
believe it was an inauguration because
he was he was Eng he was in an
interracial couple and so JFK said no I
can't do it because of Optics and then
Nixon said I don't give a he
invited him and Davis J was a republican
for the rest of his life which shows you
it's always been about Optics and using
people of different oppressed classes of
course JFK maybe wasn't a racist but he
still had to play the game and back then
Democrats like you can't do the
interracial couple thing Nixon for all
of his faults said I don't care I like
Sammy D Mr Bojangles is
catchy candyman candyman can I love that
video definitely proved that uh black
people's got us back you know black
people get your back when they start
calling you King yes exactly you King
stay up King we was Kings babe who can
mix the
races I've got a glass eye create a
m you know by the way how he lost his
eye we've talked about this before sorry
it's the it was the horn you know you
have had hood ornaments Cadillacs had
horn ornaments and they were
threedimensional and it was spiked out
towards him and it was basically a
fender bender and it went in his eyes oh
Mr Bo J oh
God for the rest of his life put that on
the why would you put that on the horn
it's almost impractical
babe I want to let someone know to put
on their turn sign I have to impale my
left Panky so there's a lot of history
there a lot of history and by the way
for the algorithm because we will be
talking about terrorism today and
there's a lot of Nefarious activity on
YouTube hit the like button hit the like
button if you uh want to see this do
well and consider joining mug Club hey
Brian K has his own show on mug club now
yes I do yes it's called off limits a
rebranding it's it's going to be good
because it was going to be the Brian Ken
show and then I found out it was off
limits and I was like all right yeah I
got tired of Bri got tired of I'm bad at
myself I'm bad at branding I was like oh
I don't like the Brian K show it just
doesn't sound dramatic enough off limits
limits limits please say it with an echo
limits limits it's still it's okay do I
feel like I can see it on the back of a
truck that'd be cool exactly he's just
looking mirror at one point you said I
can't see the laughter anymore it's off
limits all right let's go to the CBC the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
because I know you're thinking CDC they
also suck the CBC is basically
government news you don't have to go to
Venezuela and I've always said don't
just ask what it is the left does here
in the United States with checks and
balances the systems that we have ask
what they would do of completely
unfettered the greatest example the
greatest petri dish that we have is
Canada yeah also the fact that it's
allowed to exist is the greatest proof
that the United States is not an evil
empire because we should just take it we
still should just take it name me any
other Empire comment below any other go
I mean go Ottomans Turks Romans Greeks
you know take any of the dynasties that
you want go back to the ger like
anything any Empire that has ever
existed that would allow Canada to exist
if they had the United States right one
tenen of the population rich in natural
resources no na no National Defense of
which to speak M it should be the 51st
state agreed we could save money on
beaver pelts we
could drugs prescription drugs we
actually wouldn't they just actually
subsidize it from the government so we
would still have to subsid
the 5st state but oil lots of oil so the
CBC is up to its old tricks again and by
old tricks I mean the same tricks uh as
far as enforcing coded language which
brings us to this week's installment of
no
Canada so like all of the other outlets
uh they're covering the Israel um Hamas
War Israel terrorist War right Israel
versus terrorists I'm team antiterrorist
by the way me too not afraid to take
unpopular positions here I'll take the
Fleck wow so they are covering at the C
at the
CBC but with their own spin
[Applause]
here sorry wrong clip sorry guys here is
the clip of the CBC funded largely by uh
that man uh professional prime minister
blackface in Chief here's a
clip the might of Israel's Arsenal
thundered down on gaza's City ities
turning vast sads of the Palestinian
Enclave to Rubble in retaliation for
hamas's unprecedented attack Israel's
military told people to leave but many
either could not or did not and
perished okay so now some emails have
been circulating uh directly from the
CBC the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation who received their funding
from the government uh instructing
reporters to number one not mention Gaza
has not been occupied since 2005 that's
kind of a key detail right why why would
you don't mention it because we want to
say occupation okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
we don't don't P point out the fact that
almost 20 years ago Israel pulled out
they also pulled out Gerald they pull
out 24,000 plus settlers by force yeah
they pulled all of them every single one
24,000 that's and since then they've had
tunnels you know under their schools and
under their hospitals but yeah these are
Minor Details number two big one they
were instructed their reporters not to
refer to Palestinian terrorists Hamas as
terrorists they're people of Terror yes
they're people of people of Terror I
call them I call them either the
misunderstood or yes baby the formerly
known as terrorists like I don't
understand what we're I'm listen I was
misidentified as a terrorist at
Birth now I identify as a panju hater
okay
which means I can be a terrorist or I
can just hate Jews and I could go back
and forth and I can mate with someone
who is also a terrorist or hates Jews I
have all of these above but either way
they have to hate Jews it really hurts
you're acting like this is part of their
Charter come on yeah exactly it's almost
like it's not written down right it's
not written down you do that by the way
you should never put eradication in any
Charter as of human beings avoid
absolutes yeah exactly eradication Inu
there's a problem yes exactly it's like
there's no wiggle room like we don't
want wiggle room burn the boats
eradication of juice don't worry the CBC
will say this is just a it's it's just
misunderstood yeah different the email
uh that goes out again from the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation and this could
easily I say this because what do you
think would happen in the United States
when you had Jens saki calling for
Spotify to do uh to do more with Joe
Rogan to censor Joe Rogan let's call it
what it is because sometimes we say it's
not censorship unless it's government I
think that I think that the White House
communications Court would certainly
qualify what what do you think our
government would do when they're trying
to uh remove
misinformation from social media
platforms right what do you think they
would do if they had the ability to well
right now you see it with the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation effectively a
monopoly as it relates to video media uh
in the uh failed nation of Canada the
email states that Hamas are not to be
referred to as terrorists because the
notion of terrorism remains heavily
politicized and is part of the story
even when quoting or clipping a
government or a source referring to
Fighters as terrorists we should add
context to ensure the audience
understands this is opinion not
fact
incorrect why is it controversial to say
that a terrorist is a terrorist in your
opinion that's not an opinion that's
it's in your opinion look we all have
opinions but it's a fact you know what
they say they say opinions are like
they're like balloon knots right and we
all have them we all have them but the
government says that you can't express
yours but what if they say that they are
terrorists could I I have to affirm
their identity who said they're
terrorist
terrorists the the terrorists say
they're terrorists look they could
identify how they want but it's not my
job to dead dead name
them
just your compassion is overwhelming why
can't the world be more like Steven this
just hey look they're not terrorists
like no no no no no no no I think wait
hold on a second hold on
did you just say that we're not
terrorists I thought we had this we are
very clearly terrorists look at the sign
right here right yes yes right
there have you you've read the word
eradication right like we wrote it
down we tried to do it in Jew blood we
couldn't find it there weren't enough
but like we are very clear that we are
terrorists right so I you know don't try
and whitewash my
terrorism so it's opinion not fact and
by the way they are trying trying to
tell you as a reporter at the CBC that's
what's so perverse here that's what's so
subversive is they are telling their
reporters there is no way to objectively
call terrorists terrorists even if they
call themselves that and this is not
uncommon and we've also had our own
runin um with a not terrorist here in
the office I think are this still going
on out there y
[Music]
mhm are you
I assure you I'm not a terrorist you
look like a terrorist I I I assure you
I'm not I'm just your everyday average
Hassan with an AK uh yeah this my
conceal and
carry
conceal Oh I thought you were referring
to the dynamite under my gown here no
this is actually my Expos and
carry
okay
hey
guys I think that might have been a
[Music]
terrorist it's just so it's hard to tell
now we don't have blue and red coats to
be clear that is an opinion not a fact I
just need to make sure that we stay in
compliance with the CBC there's a new
move in uh like now with Das where they
they're calling people that commit
crimes victims as well because they they
are yes they are because their their
circumstances have led their
victimization have led them to act out
right and kill people I would like to
act out on them yes
yes that didn't come out the way you
thought it but the principal yes the
principal remains did we clip that it
wasn't like a Domin kind of thing it was
more no no no I get it's a power move
it's a power move like in prison rape is
not gay if it's just to make him feel
bad it's not at all what I going on the
board for it's a power Mo I'll tell you
a real power move is the uh my version
of exposed carry it's when I'm exposed
and I'm carry yes exactly yes that's a
twofer yeah you don't want to see me at
a mall either they don't know which is
more threatening like the firearm or wow
Hammer good for you Josh now I call that
prison theater
Hammer um know what that means so what
look and i i i before I I'm
foreshadowing here why do you think
again comment below these are these
things always end up being clipped and
some of you guys only watch 30 seconds
why do you think the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation is so quick to
defend
Hamas now let's give you some context
you remember this is the same
Broadcasting Corporation who described
Canadian truckers right who are
protesting the coid mandates now to be
clear the coid mandates were M way more
severe in Canada than in the United
States and in 2022 trucker said we are
not going to comply with with these
mandates vaccine mandates lockdown
mandates they were referred to by the
CBC as extremist ideologues
H and their bank at first they froze the
donations to the truckers then bank
accounts y then their cryptocurrency
amazing it's insane think about that so
that's kind of something you would do to
terrorists I mean I know we don't do it
with the Iranian regime we're we're
unfreezing $6 billion that's to the
ayatolla but freezing it uh you know for
people who are shipping out McCain's
Pizza which by if you're Canadian you
guys you guys catch that reference
McCain it's like it's like their Douro
whatever do you guys have Douro in the
states I don't need yeah it's not
delivery it's Douro M yeah but we had
McCain cares thank
you so so truckers get their bank
accounts Frozen under the can let's be
clear about this again you have to
understand that Joe Biden loves Trudeau
right it's really the Trudeau the only
person who I guess loves Joe Biden is
Trudeau he's respected by no foreign
leader there's mutual respect there so
let's just be really C under the
Canadian broadcasting corporation's
definition of terrorism okay we
have
terrorism yeah not
terrorism so just to be clear let me
just just in case I just want to make
sure one more time so
terrorism not
terrorism stage left stage right it's
hard for me to know great yeah jeez make
it the 51st state that's this week's
installment of no
[Music]
Canada did you have something else you
wanted to add there Jo no I just gave
you a thumbs up oh okay good he was just
making so let's move on to uh equally
reprehensible I mean that was an entity
the CBC but now we have AOC yeah CBC AOC
same thing these are the ABCs and how
many days in a we what did I call like
three four days until they started
turning on Israel they got a little bit
Bit of Sympathy for a couple of days in
the minute that they actually tried to
stand up and defend themselves yeah got
Canada now we've got AOC we've got other
people to be clear AOC did kind of
condemn uh the Hamas attacks on Israel
and you know I will give credit where
it's du when Biden finally you know
emerg from his because we might have six
more weeks win later yes um he he
condemned it wholeheartedly it was late
but he didn't both sides it that that
was good I will give him credit where
it's due they wrote his speech very
effectively now AOC condemned Hamas kind
of initially but she just couldn't help
herself from blaming the Jews it's just
it's so hard not to so this is and this
is why you might see the YouTube dump
button they've asked us not to do the
segment personally but we do it anyway
so you can watch it on Rumble uh and if
you have kids they shouldn't be watching
we're all a little bit angry today it's
time for this week's what a piece of
[Music]
mea a
o m I'm just reading what I did what
does that mean and of course that being
said we're all grateful that just by the
skin of her teeth she avoided the pipe
bomb in DC though right we are glad by
the six blocks yeah I mean yes point is
two things can be true here's aoc's
official statement on the situation in
Israel okay I condemn hamas's attack on
the strongest possible terms no child
and family should ever endure this kind
of violence and fear and this violence
will not solve the ongoing oppression
and occupation in the region ah there we
like CBC you don't talk about the fact
that they haven't been in Gaza since
2005 amazing then she goes on to say and
and by the way this is this is why I
hate John lennin when people just say
Give Peace a chance it's stupid and I
say this as a non-interventionist is
someone who unless it's in our national
security interest you let the dice fall
where they may in the rest of the world
right we do not need to be in the
business of nation building just to be
clear but this idea that well I just
want peace oh that if that's all that
was required for peace then there would
never need to be a conversation one
person would just say peace oh great
done all oxin free got it everyone's
like oh okay I guess we put the away our
bums because you two said so so then she
goes on to say this is why you need to
understand this language if someone says
ceasefire that's they are supporting
Hamas an immediate ceasefire and
deescalation is urgently needed to save
lives now let me be let me try and paint
this scenario for you as clearly as I
possibly can someone comes into your
house rapes your wife or your child
kills members of your family says that
they are going to be back tomorrow at
the same time to do it again and you
decide that you need to defend yourself
and you want to purchase a firearm no no
no now we implement the ceasefire after
the damage has already been done that is
not Justice that is evil calling for a
ceasefire when people have been murdered
targeted and brutal innoc people by
Design targeted is evil the calling for
a ceasefire is not virtuous it's evil
you know what we have some visual aids
here uh if you all remember Braveheart
we we've Rewritten it an assault on the
king's
soldiers is the same as an assault on
the king
himself ceasefire ceasefire come on guys
calm down cease
fire yeah that helps yeah makes me feel
it's essentially p a chance guys I don't
think that she would uh you have lost
sorry oh I was say I don't think she
would ask for a ceasefire like at a
school shooting or something like that
right she won't be like oh no no the the
guy's done he's right out of bullets
let's let's take it easy yeah let's just
you've lost you lost your right to any
of that I got too many bullets I got to
get rid of at this point yeah and and I
think a lot of people AR talking about
this the best thing that you could do
probably for the Palestinians in Gaza is
Crush Hamas that's the first thing and
also this idea that when you bring in
the Israeli Palestinian conflict uh to
somehow justify or explain what Hamas
did on October 7th is a little bit and
I'm and I'm being dead serious little
bit like you get a serial killer and he
goes you kill he killed he cut off 10
women's heads M and it's like but you
know what his mom treated him really
badly when well that happens well fire
then I mean we got to let him continue
no no no sorry sorry yeah you've lost
your right to that yeah we need to crush
you get rid of you kill all of them well
the Hamas you just kill all of Hamas
Hamas you just up and this is the
end of you now sorry and by the way I
think it need to be worse than but go
ahead J I think it need to be worse than
killing them for the first time in
history we have a nation that warns you
hold on pause why is Earthworm Jim on
CNN right
now by the way
go to full screen that is earthworm gim
it is but do not do not gloss over this
early us Intel C doubts on Direct
Iranian involvement right now the US
government is carrying water for the
Iranians they already said so well of
course they have doubts they gave them
the money yes well I don't I doubt they
use my money on the what do you mean by
direct you mean by direct do you think
that is this like the mob boss thing
where it's like yeah he obviously
ordered the hit but he didn't actually
say the word so there's not direct
Iranian involvement you cowards call
them what they are and deal with it so
that we don't have this you know what
people have said I want to save lives
right now A you want to save lives do
you want it to go on for 75 more years
because I'm pretty sure more than a
couple of thousand people are going to
die in the next 75 years if this problem
is not solved the problem is Hamas their
terrorists take them out one state
solution one state solution at this
point one state Solution that's it hey
you have a problem take it up with Egypt
you about to say something else before I
cut you off with earthworm gy on a
little p the way did you lose your train
of thought on no no I I it was basically
a little bit of that okay A little bit
of what I said you said death is is too
good what were you trying to say we need
to embarrass them because here's the
thing you need to understand about
terrorists um they're they follow this
ideology this religion and again it's
not all but 190 I think it was 198
million 198 or 194 million go to
yesterday's show link is in the
description by the way all references we
make publicly Available to You 198
million Muslims right now on Earth
believe that violence against civilians
is at least somewhat Justified over 50
million believe it's usually Justified
often Justified that's too much and
certainly all of H and the people who
elected Hamas now here's what you have
to understand with those people who
believe that ideology um the only Shire
way to heaven is Jihad yep is Jihad in
the eradication largely of Christians
and Jews and their religion just to be
that's why you see a lot of these
suicide bombers hitting up strip clubs
and you know do and blow before they
weren't doing it for their entire lives
but once they decided they were going to
commit Jihad it's all absolved right so
you can't you can't defeat these people
through simply uh death they they want
death there's also by the way a vested
interest for Hamas to keep their people
poor to keep those people longing for
death death is a good out for them think
about it if you're living right now
Hamas is the one who who puts bombs in
Children's Schools Hamas is the one who
decides to turn their own hospitals into
targets Hamas is the one who prevents
The Warning Systems so that their own
people can be safe so they have to live
under constant Terror not because of the
Israelis who are warning them and
sending them a targeted map but because
Hamas wants to keep them p wants to keep
them hopeless so that they can breed
terrorism where there's one way out
there's one way out Jihad you're
guaranteed a spot in heaven so that
means you can do as much blow off the uh
the old bur's hip bones as you want but
but it also they take care embarrassment
needs to that's why that's why you had
special forces dipping bullets uh in
Pig's blood yeah because they have a
very physical view of Heaven you phys
you go with you don't have your
perfected body you have your current
body they need to be shamed yeah they
fear shame more than death they long for
death
because their stupid evil ideology
creates a world that is far worse than
death yeah you can't defeat them through
death though I also want death
right I want my cake I want to eat it
too yes and look I I I I hope this ends
quickly but like you the point that I
was going to make I actually remembered
it was that you have a nation that warns
you hey we're about to bomb this area
and they're like people who couldn't get
out or who didn't couldn't why couldn't
they I understand maybe you can't get
out of Gaza you go down the Street you
can maybe get away from the Hamas
headquarters or when we see all the
rubble pictures right now that was where
most of the Hamas leaders lived that's
what they blew up that was the Beverly
Hills of the Hamas people right that's
what was you know to get away from that
this is Hamas Hilton guy and more of
Hamas Wilshire this is the last thing
this is the last thing Israel wanted to
do for so many reasons and it gets to a
point where you have to say we have to
take the profit out of this country kind
of behavior yeah if you think that
there's any value or benefit to Iran or
to the leadership of Hamas and going in
there and killing innocent people and
cutting babies heads off etc etc and
taking hostages well the the message has
to be made that that all of you are
going to die now all you guys every one
of you guys that gave the orders and
everything else I hope it was worth it
cuz now we're at the point of no return
and there is no ceasefire I think you
said you need to take the value out of
it you also need to take the the prophet
you also need to take the Valor out of
it yeah that's why what AOC is doing in
the CBC is so evil because do you know
what to them is Valor victims victim
status look the Jews look at us look how
oppressed we are look look it's just
it's their equivalent to the gender
queer pansexual bold cuted lesbian chain
gangs you have here in the United States
they want the whole world to see how
oppressed they are when their entire
Charter their entire reason for existing
is to eradicate Jews you need to take
the Valor out of it so when you when
when you portray them you portray them
as animals who are the bullies this is
all this is what sociopaths do they
bully you and they accuse you of being a
bully a lot of people don't realize this
sociopaths are generally not like
physically violent people they're
manipulative people so they go hey you
called me out in person you're
straightforward you're a bully and then
they go around and they try and destroy
your life right they go to other people
it's gossip gossip is mentioned in the
bible more times than even sexual
immorality it is the most deadly sin and
this is what we have with the left we
have a culture of Gossip rag we have a
culture of the CBC telling the reporters
what they can and cannot say and we
portray these people exactly how they
want to be portrayed victims they are
not they are evil terrorists who need to
be shamed before they die let me go back
to AOC she uh by the way also condemned
the Democratic Socialist uh sponsored
Pro Hamas rallies in NYC which is nice
yeah she said we will not allow bigotry
to destroy a community and city in this
devastating moment islamophobia
anti-Semitism and victim blaming cannot
be tolerated we can plus will reject it
all that's not hard we must focus on the
lives currently uh at stake now if
Switzerland was a person yes and this
was the first tweet this was the first
tweet by the way from her personal
account first public tweet from her
account it's a repost yes and it's a
repost because the video she posted
accompanying that tweet um where she
says we have to stop anti-Semitism just
notice this is she is a tool of
propaganda now you can't blame her she's
stupid true very very true so she said
we have to stop all of
but the only accompanying
video it reads like I don't want to say
anti-sm it reads like anti-jew
propaganda here's the video that was
included in her tweet kill all
Palestinians all of them now one left
from The River To The Sea palestin will
be deceased and Israel need to do like
this you see now Gaza like this Gaza I
need to do like this oh oh like this but
all this
Jewish the options what do you what do
you think it's like she found an
anti-semitic
cartoon talking about every now
keep in mind this is in response to
women rap murder nothing El you can do
they they prove they prove there nothing
this clip is we can we can cut it we
wanted to show you most so you can see
the context to be clear these are Jews
who are so angry that they want to wipe
out any of Hamas and probably some of
them Palestinian
only said an's the of video thats a
there's the antism where where all of
the celebrations that we've seen across
the Western World saying we are pro
Palestine no Israel down is what are you
talking about that was in Australia I
think that they were chanting that
Sydney Opera house it was incredible and
by the way it's pretty clear how AOC
feels about the Jews if you just go by
the dress that she wore to the rally
which you know I mean I don't know how
you can order anything on Ali Buba
idea that big juicy booty so let me give
you a couple of fast facts because then
we have uh do we do we have Lawrence Fox
we have just a few minutes oh we have in
just a few minutes okay and he's calling
in from London so fast fact one you go
back to September 2021 AOC had to
apologize to her constituents for voting
present and not voting no on the new
Iron Dome funding right and she put this
out there she said to those that have
disappointed I am deeply sorry yes I
wept well that's a good start wept I
wept at the complete lack of care for
the human beings that are impacted by
these decisions I wept at an institution
choosing a path of Maximum volatility
and minimum consideration for its own
political convenience now just to be
clear the Iron Dome is it's kind of like
the per I said I I I don't understand
this but I do that certain bulletproof
vests are illegal for civilians that's a
defensive tool it's a defensive tool
it's you're not going to maybe someone
was beaten over the head with a flack
jacket okay I don't know but the point
is you don't typically use it as a
weapon this is a defensive tool it's a
shield it's not a sword and so she was
against she believes it's too volatile
for Israel to have the right to defend
itself the Iron Dome it shoots out
Rockets being fired at their civilians
midair here's a clip and it's really
cool damn look at all that political
convenience
yes oppressors how dare you shoot that
our Rockets see I and I see oppression
and I see them being shot down I see
escalation yes according to AOC those
should just be able to hit the ground
and kill people and then we'll deal with
right right now like oh how can you go
back in and kill himas like yeah but you
know what you said that it was
aggression when we were just firing
their Rockets out of the
air but those were Hamas Rockets
expensive Rockets yes do you have any
idea how much Rockets go for these days
it's hard for us to fire them at you you
should let them land inflation spares no
one all that Iranian training yes just
for not so unfair and it's a it's a it's
a nation of people incapable of growing
muscle so it took a lot of work to load
that up we got a hostage back for the
money that paid for those Rockets yes
yes exactly I think so I have no idea
Britney grer no wait we gave The
Merchant of death the point is don't
shoot Rockets out of the air let them
hit the people here's another fact May
15th 2021 after Israel bombed a Gaza
building which was housing uh the AP
also Al jazer AOC tweeted out apar
States aren't democracies now again the
building was being used by Hamas just to
be clear it was like HQ yes and Israel
warned them hey you're housing Hamas
sorry terrorists you're housing
terrorists so we are going to launch an
attack against this building because
it's housing terrorists yes very
different than fort nighting in on hang
gliders and kidnapping women and
children from a fesal and then her only
comment was Apartheid States okay but
that's not relevant right now right they
they called they emailed they candy
grammed like they tried to get everybody
out yeah it's literally a separate issue
yeah they sent the non Hamas terrorists
tiffs treats I heard your buildings
falling down
yes so here's another uh there's a key
fact number three for I'm making the
case that AOC is uh is actually an
anti-semite she actually doesn't like
the Jews July 18th 2023 she voted no on
a resolution that would support Israel
the resolution which passed 412 to9 came
after uh one of her Squad I guess let me
not just say Squad because Squad right
they have an official Squad this is
someone who's Squad adjacent Junior
Squad yeah yeah it's like Doom Patrol
got it's like not really but first
string but it's uh prila jaipal I guess
or jaipal called Israel a quote unquote
racist State ah okay and then AOC
responded to this comment from Nikki
Haley I guess you would call it Nikki
Haley's criticism which was valid um
this is uh it says a remember to call it
people in Congress who think apari is
wrong is what she said to defend herself
remember to call it people in Congress
who think AP parite is wrong or
alternatively people in Congress who
don't ignore human rights abuses against
Palestinian yeah but you said firing
their deadly Rockets aimed at civilians
in the sky was an abuse of Human Rights
I don't know whose rights are being
abused like here's the thing if some if
we had the ability if we somehow had the
ability to create a weapon like for home
defense that could literally just stop
bullets midair like fire them out of the
I would think we could all find Comm
like that' even be better than a gun I
could stop their bullets you know and
then I also have a gun because i' return
fire but the point is yes there's
nothing wrong with if it could Matrix
that yeah be so cool the matrixx
ACT they're against the defensive tool
of the Iron Dome that's a violation of
Human Rights hey that Jew's fighting
back get them
so if AOC really does right if she
really cares about anti-Semitism maybe
we should maybe we should go to one of
our galal Squad members Rashid Tay and
talk about the rampant anti-Semitism
which anyone who's from Michigan by the
way comment below if you're from
Michigan and you know about Dearborn uh
a lot of people get it wrong you can
hear the Muslim call to prayer in
Hamtramck I believe not actually in
Dearborn um but it's a very Muslim place
and uh it's a very anti-semitic place
and rashita T obviously this is her Ian
these are her stomping grounds and these
I mean she Stomps so here's a clip from
De born from the river to the sea from
The River To The Sea Palestine will be
free pal
no
justice now this is a message to all the
activists and leaders out there that are
condemning anti-Semitism and condemning
terrorism right stop it stop you are not
helping all right you are playing their
game yes you are playing their game by
condemning the murder and rape and
torture of women and children yes also
by the way kidnapped Americans just so
you know we know about that now killed
Americans kidnapped Americans he went on
to say we've been saying that for 20 30
40 years if they don't believe it now
that we're not anti-semitic they're
never going to yes that's the problem we
do not believe it we don't believe it
yes you say one thing and then you do
another thing and the other thing is
killing Jews and so that seems
anti-semitic to me I'm getting mixed
signals I am too but they're prisoners
of War not hostages and they're
misunderstood yes that's true not
terrorists terrorist not not hostages
I'm sure the four-year-old they were
parading through the street as a
prisoner of war yeah I'm I'm sure look
there are probably a couple of Hamas
members whose dad didn't hug them enough
and you have to look at their childhoods
yeah yeah yeah exactly get to the why
yeah I'll look through their childhood
pictures uh after I you know sift
through the wreckage of their smoldering
corpses hope I've crystallized it for
you I still got bullets in this gun yeah
I'm Chuck full of bullets CE
what sorry I I'm playing an soldier from
19 it's like a 1920s
mobster yeah going to have some going to
have some shish Hamas that's all it is
I'm from Brooklyn but I'm Jewish you've
heard of baked Alaska be baked toas oh
look at a big flame over there oh be a
shame if we fired down your missiles and
uh launched them over here he's an
Italian guy pretending to be Jewish yeah
you know listen we all we're similar
we're both
loud we got better food yeah we do look
matab ball it's just it's nothing
there's no flavor it's bread and soup
it's clogging up your heart it's make
try some try some fish Fish and Rice
BR so I know something by the way this
is back from what 2014 2015 remember the
gay wedding cake controversy well I went
to Dearborn to try and find Muslim
bakeries to bake a gay wedding cake now
to be fair and I told you guys in the
original video I think one or two did uh
but it only took one with Christians in
the United States right one who wouldn't
take part in a gay wedding the vast
majority in Dearborn uh didn't even have
a chip for
[Music]
it it's going to be me and any well you
have pictures there no machine you have
in
Kroger in Kroger
yeah this is what you do here no I don't
want it I don't want it he very friendly
was like I don't want too much too much
coook to be fair you wanted him to make
a penis cake so no I didn't I just
wanted a cake with a picture of me my
love I know ad normal cake yeah to be
fair to be fair your husband's not a
tractor no I think he just I think he
just didn't agree with your relationship
he just you weren't right for each other
look he know you both look like tops yes
I'm saying like so got bot no you can't
have a two and an
eight when he looked around for a tall
building that's when I got concerned for
you so he don't I don't want it yeah and
by the way let's also keep this leader
uh Ismail uh I believe it's Hanah Han
it's pronounce Han um that uh God bless
you here here he is he's one of their
leaders of of of Dearborn when he he he
called uh for uh global
action
so I think basically that's a Hamas
leader and and basically did he have the
people of Dearborn in mind because he
said regardless of your geography no
matter where you are in the world join
this fight yeah hamic by the way only uh
only city in America with a majority uh
Muslim population right it's not
Dearborn no no everyone thinks Dearborn
Hamra 60% Hamtramck and I don't worry if
you're not from Michigan you wouldn't
pronounce it correctly used to be all
Pollocks anymore is that what it was it
was all Pollocks I blame a Abraham for
all of this yeah well the whole blessing
and the thigh thing you know you got to
bring Isaac up on that that area on that
mount none of it makes sense there's no
oil in the ground there's nothing but
dates until you understand that the Jews
lied about everything according to
Muhammad so uh before we before we bring
him on do we want to uh set this up with
some clips yeah we can set it up really
quick all right let's set this up
because our next guest we have here is
is uh Lawrence Fox he was a host at GB
news right by the way which was a right
leaning uh news agency he was a
candidate for London mayor
and he's been in trouble for you know
again when you deal with Europe we just
talked about Canada you have speech and
you have thought crimes um oh wait a
second we need to book end before we
bring him on we need to close that
chapter with a that has been this week's
AOC what a piece of
[Music]
back to Lawrence Fox we had to get
that out of our system probably waiting
in the wings so uh there are thought
crimes and there are speech CRI this is
the problem with hate speech this is the
problem with hate crimes hate crimes
lead to hate speech laws and hate speech
laws lead to hate thought laws where
they say ah but you were thinking it I
like hold on a second I I I just I
committed a crime yeah but you did but
the guy you committed against was black
so it's a hate crime well it's already a
crime I me I knocked over a liquor store
it's like ah we're going to add hate
crime that way we can say that's hate
speech you can't speak out against and
hate speech by the way can even be uh
you know for example referring to a man
as he and then maybe you talk you go
he ah you were thinking he so now we're
going to put you in jail so Fox Lawrence
Fox was first fired by what is assumed
to be conservative leaning GB news after
and look I'm going to let you guys know
these you may think that these remarks
are are are pretty rough but uh I don't
really have a problem with it he made
these remarks about uh a feminist and
I'm going to give you some context on
why he made these remarks uh her name is
Ava
Evans What wave of feminism are we on is
it fourth fifth at this juncture we're
pass the water shed so I can say this um
show me a single self-respecting man
that would like to climb into bed with
that woman ever ever who wasn't an incel
who wasn't a cup little incel that
little woman has been fed spoonfed
oppression day after day after day after
day starting with the LIE of the gender
uh uh wage Gap and she sat there and I'm
going like if I met you in a bar and
that was like sentence three chances of
me just walking away are just huge we
need powerful strong amazing women who
make great points for themselves we
don't need these sort of feminist 4.0
they're pathetic and embarrassing who'd
want
that it's hard to argue with that logic
now what the guy said the guy after that
goes I mean she is rather beautiful I
think and I saw her no damage control
that's what we call a
lie OB be across a pond we call french
fries chips and we call that a
lie I believe you mean to say half truth
sir no I mean a lie so what prompted him
to make this comment uh Mr Fox is and
this is a subject that's been near and
dear to our heart because many people um
here have been affected by it where Ava
Evans the feminist was downplaying
completely um the problem really an
epidemic of male suicide I'm saying that
there are specific issues that men face
that might warrant specific attention I
mean literally the biggest killer of of
men under 50 is suicide I think that it
feeds into the culture a little bit this
Minister for men argument like that in
my mind I think there should be a
minister for mental health which should
be all-encompassing I the
number mental health at the moment it's
a crisis that's endemic throughout the
country not specific to men and I think
you know a lot of ministers kind of
Bandy this about to sort of I'm sorry
but make an enemy out of women make an
enemy out of women well in the United
States alone 2022 79% of suicides were
men that number goes far higher if you
go to middle-aged men and far higher as
a percentage if you go to White
middle-aged men it is largely
exclusively a white middle-aged male
problem just to be clear you cannot
address the problem if you downplay it
and you've seen feminists be even worse
than oh yeah oh sorry little white
privilege man are you well hold second
hold on second I get it that you think
you're making 77 cents in the dollar
which by the way considering how Artic
would be absolutely overpay
but we die
men kill themselves in record numbers we
make up all of the workplace deaths and
we make up all of the suicides that
tells you that there's a problem that
men cannot
overcome the final solution suicide 79%
in United States 2022 alone Depend and
again once you take out teenagers sorry
once you take out transgender
individuals that number is well into the
80s sometimes in the 90s if you're
talking about middle-aged white men if
you're just looking at those
demographics it's a very serious problem
and not one that we just talk about it's
not opinion it's a fact now after that
Lawrence Fox was arrested on October 4th
for um or I don't know it was after that
but at one point he got in trouble he
apparently encouraged uh vandalism is
what they claim of ultra low emission
Zone after uh enforcement cameras now to
be clear what these things these are
actually uh cameras that help the city
of London charge a daily fee for
driving yeah so if you drive through the
Zone because of in a a car yeah in a car
if you driving a car a normal car that
means that means that your car is likely
right there are likely emission this is
to cut down on congestion yes no well
not just congestion it's also
eco-friendly oh they're going they're
going to cool the planet by by cutting
down on on congestion in in London in
the middle of London yes exactly oh
that'll cool the planet also there's no
way that these could be used to invade
your privacy never no so we were going
to show you um the offending clip but I
guess we we pulled that because it had
something in it that we he he can't say
oh
so we didn't want to
get bring bring the man on well here's
well do we want to show the okay all
right let's just you know it's time to
bring you can follow him on X at L Oz Za
Fox they say Zed I say Z laza Fox it's
time to bring on our guest today Mr
Lawrence
[Music]
Fox Mr Fox can you hear me see me sir I
can Stephen how are you doing I'm oh boy
it's a shock I watched that clip and you
had the haircut like Eric Maxis and now
you went with C Conor so is this is this
a protest what you have a good head ofe
well I knew I knew I was going to get uh
locked up at some point so I thought I
might as well get ready for the goolag
you know what I mean yeah well we have
that clip of the police searching your
house um which we were going to show but
I figured it's just best to bring you on
at this point um for those people who
who don't know run the viewer right now
or listener through kind of the series
of events that led to you being and I
hate to say this fired let go from G I
mean I don't say that to you know rub
salt in the wound but you know you got
canned well fortunately I didn't call I
mean perhaps I should have called for
the eradication of the Jews because then
I would be fine I'd still be in in a job
um no yes this this woman a EV this this
woman a Evans went on about I mean I
still cringe listening to it drives me
mad she just tried to belittle the idea
that men have mental health problems
that really annoyed me my point was what
any man who comes across a woman like
that and who makes a union with a woman
like that is committing himself to a
life of abject misery yeah and that was
my point Could I Have Made It In A
Better Way in the TAC Point yeah
probably but GB news got all upset
because the left is so good at
organizing and uh getting the pile on
mobs so they then got worried that they
do hilariously call themselves the home
of free speech which I find quite
amazing and then they fired me they then
fired a friend of mine who stood up for
me and um then on the Monday I've been
criticizing this the May of London I got
to be really careful here because I've
got a lot of bail conditions in this uh
the Britain The Crucible of free speech
um I was criticizing a scam climate uh
tax that was being bought in by the
mayor to to make a surveillance state in
in our country and I criticized that and
um and sure enough on the Tuesday
Morning the uh the police came barreling
through the door to uh to arrest me and
take me off to jail where I where I
spent the day and they they want to
charge me I think for conspiracy to
commit CRI criminal damage but yet again
but all I had to do was go out into
Parliament square and say gas the Jews
and I'd be fine right and just to be
clear for people who are clipping this
uh you know I don't believe that he
wants to gas the Jews that would be
Rashida T just to be just to be clear
because they'll try and cut it yes or or
most of the left uh Metropolitan in
London London who are apologizing for
the appalling stuff that's going on in
uh Israel today yeah well they're
apologizing for the response from while
they also have the rainbow Flags which I
don't think they'll be waving uh over
you know over Gaza anytime soon um
here's one thing too I mean a lot of
people in America don't realize that
Free Speech doesn't Exist Elsewhere uh
as it does in the United States
enshrined into our constitution I was
raised in Canada it's a silly place we
still have your queen on our money uh
and uh in the United States there is a
rugged individualism I mean we've
covered stories for example in the UK
there was a man who was arrested for
doing a cover he at a karaoke night kung
fu fighting and someone said that it was
racism like this has been going on for a
long time so when the rules keep
changing right it's a mine field and now
it's someone walking backwards laying
down mines it's these are just tools to
politically imprison anyone um you want
why would why would you even go into a
system like that is what people may ask
if you kind of could see the writing on
the wall it seems like this was
inevitable they can arrest you for
anything you
say yeah I mean I think my point was to
push it obviously we've got the uh the
environmental U Aztec doomsday cult uh
who sit and blocks the the bridges in
London and um you know ambulances can't
get in to to save people and the police
give them glasses of water while they
superglue their hands to each other
moronic little weirdos that they are and
then um London bridg is shutting down
that's I think the new Nursery room yeah
so so I was like um I was like hang on
if the law is not applied equally then
it's not a law it's a political weapon
and hence hence we proved it we in in
Britain it the problem here is it it's
accelerating at a record speed
it's unbelievable what What's Happening
Here we have no protections on our Free
Speech the law isn't applied equally we
don't have presumption of innocence
therefore we don't have a functioning
democracy in my view right that's a huge
problem some other people would add to
it uh concering Eva Evans who you
criticized that a huge problem you you
have there in Britain is yappy
so we're now on the like seemingly don't
worry we have the view here uh like
thousand version of feminism and women
are more unhappy than
ever why do you think they keep pushing
this because it seems accelerated over
there in the UK when it the results very
clearly speak for themselves women are
less happy than
ever I don't know I think I think that
we've got a particular problem here that
the you know as the Progressive Movement
swept through our culture we've had two
generations now who've been told that
all they have to do is apologize you
just must apologize apologize apologize
so that breeds kind of weak men who just
go I'm really sorry I'm sorry for being
Christian I'm sorry for being white I'm
sorry for being stood next to you uh
please take my job my house my you know
please come in open border and we're
just apologists and I think that women
have got men in order to get laid in the
UK men have to pretend to be feminists
you know and that makes them even weaker
and um but the problem is women don't
like weak men they hate weak Men
actually so it's sort of no one wins in
this situation it's a sort of sad
pathetic thing yeah it's like joining a
club that you don't want to be a part of
and they don't want you as a member um
it seems like there was uh I don't want
to say a turning point but in your
career you definitely became more
outspoken spoken right was there a
specific Catalyst or event like do you
did you have a flash of genius moment
where you said all right you know what
I'm taking the shackles off kavar the
kavar hearings was it for me weirdly and
then I I sat there and I was working as
an actor I worked as an actor for 22
years and I was sat on set with you know
actors are not renowned to be the
smartest people in the world they're
good at pretending to be emotional but
they're not smart and these people going
get to believe the women we must believe
the women we must believe them and I'm
like believe women because women
lie just do due process of the law and
see what happens yeah and you know and
obviously there is a problem with Under
reporting of of of sexual crimes against
women but there's also an over reporting
of sexual crimes against men and as you
said in your Preamble men do a lot of
the dying in this Society so um that's
what turned me I thought about it I I've
been watching you for years I've been
watching the Del wire for years I've
been watching um Ruben for years and and
I just thought you know what I can't lie
anymore I'm done with this I'd rather
clean toilets and tell the truth than
lie and be rich well I want to ask you
something too and then we're going to
continue with on mug Club where you can
just let it fly and I know you have to
be careful obviously because this is you
know there is no due process but um it's
one of those issues where uh you know
what okay actually where's the best
place for people to follow you and we
will go to mug Club just because I feel
I I feel like this is something that
could not that we'll get in trouble on
Rumble but we've gone over time it's laa
Fox on X formerly Twitter is there
another place where people can go to
support you uh yeah I run a political
party called the reclaim party so you
can follow that as well and we're about
Free Speech the reclaim party and so you
are still you're still active even
though they've done this yeah yeah until
until I'm they lock me up for I don't
know not using a paper straw I'll I'll
stay for as long as I can yeah you know
that's out of everything you know it's
like the little things that you know
when people talk about uh you know
you're at the end of your rope it's
always the little things it's like a
like the paper straw like you're not and
you're like ah I just want to kill
myself and it's just because the paper
straw is what it is it's like not
everything else that you went you're
like ah it's just the paper straw or H I
ran out of sticky notes you know
whatever it
is and then people go what happened I he
su suicide note just said he ran out of
sticky notes and everything tasted like
a number two pencil he's dead uh all
right well we'll go continue with mug
Club I appreciate and I want to get into
this more because boy is there a dynamic
at play uh with a UK that is terrifying
everyone right now if you're watching
lc.com mugclub you hit this button if
you're watching on Rumble and you get to
keep watching for another 45 minutes
today Gerald might wake up I think he
had some questions almost all right
YouTube piss
[Applause]
off
[Music]